the movie is just this cultural moment
that you've created
I was alley for Halloween I will admit
and yes I was I was I tied frozen peas
to my hands no frozen peas it's such a
cultural moment you're getting so much
incredible recognition for it as well
how do these moments like tonight feel
how are you taking it all in tonight is
a really interesting one just because in
sort of the thought of it makes me want
to just crawl into a hole but then when
I really just sit back I just really
want to actually enjoy it and embrace it
and the fact that so many my friends are
here and we're raising money for a great
foundation of American Cinematheque you
know they actually you know the Egyptian
theater in LA actually refurbished the
whole thing it opened in 2016 so the
fact it's a good cause for sustaining
motion pictures is a great benefit than
the fact that I could help them out be
here Lady Gaga's separation here yeah
how is you guys's relationship now
because you built such a trust for the
movie you've talked about that as all
the awards season stuff is happening how
much are you staying in touch how are
you getting each other through all this
craziness well you know she's very busy
but we we text and and we see each other
you know every couple of weeks I love
doing Q&A so so we've done a couple of
those together
and are you guiding her through it all
like here's how the Oscars and all this
buzz goes well there's none of that yet
but uh but no I don't guy I just sort of
know well you guys have said that you
would do an Oscars performance what can
you tease about what that would be like
way too premature let's wait and see
well how does it feel you mentioned
friends and family how does it feel for
you to have Irina and your family here
as you're going through all these
amazing moments family is everything
you've made a movie that like you know a
few kids and one day that they look back
and watch it what do you think they'll
think of everything you did gosh I you
know I have no idea it'd probably be
very surreal to watch that yeah
thank you for my Halloween
[Music]